you've got a particle and by the way
because they're in kinematics and we're
not interested in why this object is
moving this like what what forces are
impacting on it air is just it's that's
kind of thing the reason why they say
particles so often is to try and get
away from art it's an object and the
bigger it is the more resistance its
encountering or the bigger mass it has
the point is I'm not interested in any
of those so you'll see a particle or a
point they come out over and over again
we try to consider a massless volumous
object it's a party it's really
according to this equation where X is
the displacement from the origin after T
seconds from time zero ok so what do we
think about this all I figured is just a
function right at a given time I'll know
my given displacement so let's just do
some values when time is zero my initial
condition where am I
so that's not traumatic what does this
mean the context of the question will
usually tell you what this means right
now they're just meaning okay where are
you they haven't set up down there and
haven't described the axis but I'm on
one side of the origin I'm going to just
call this the negative side thank at
time 1 1 minus 4 that's gonna be
negative 3 at time 2 when you substitute
that in 2 squared minus 4 is 0 so at
this point after 2 seconds I pass the
origin right because it says there I
relative my starting point right is
relative to the origin ok so I started
you know negative 4 units on the
negative 4 units on the negative side
and now I'm at the origin time 3 5 thank
you so I blow straight policy argument
from the negative side to the poles in
your side
well the negative signs to the positive
side whichever way you want to think
about it so there's some information now
let's have a look at puppy hence find
the average velocity during the first
second this is so important I'm actually
going to write this pout and you've got
a whole bunch of different so you don't
confuse them average velocity
and by the way please please don't skip
saying the word or notifying learning
that it's the average velocity it's very
different to just velocity on its own
we'll talk about that next lesson
average velocity over first second now
this is a bit tricky because what you've
got here is this table represents me
taking a picture every second and I've
got particular instances in time but
where is the first second where is it on
this table the first second is in
interval right an inch of all the time
it's between it's the interval time
between zero and one do you agree with
that the first second begins at T equals
zero okay the first second begins at T
equals zero and it lasts for one second
so over this time I've tried to work out
a change in displacement over the change
in time that's all I need to worry about
so how far have I traveled in this
little space I've traveled one unit
right have I traveled in the positive
direction or the negative direction I've
gone in a positive direction right this
number is bigger than what it was before
so I'm going through the I'm just going
to say to the right okay so I'm going to
say this is one that's my change in
displacement you see over what's the
change in time again this is just okay
now they've said well okay so my
direction is built into this because
it's the sign of what I'm talking about
right if for example I went from
negative 3 to negative 4 I'd say there'd
be a minus sign here right so I would
then interpret that negative based on
what the question told me here they
haven't said left or right or anything
so I'm just gonna have to say the
negative direction okay now one last
thing they actually provided us units of
displacement and units of time in the
question what are they
meters and seconds one meter per second
that's my average velocity over the
first second okay
all right the first two seconds again
I'm going to buy it down average
velocity over first okay so this time
have a look again on my diagram right
this is my first second but my first two
seconds have to go all the way over this
interval do you see that start at equal
zero and it ends at T equals two so I go
over the same kind of process right how
far have I traveled in this type here
four meters in the positive direction so
I'm just gonna write positive four and
how long did it take me what was the
change of time this is not it's not
complicated but the concept is really
important to get firm in your mind okay
should be saying this is fine okay um
I'm going to skip over path three
because I think you get the idea but I
want to go right to platform
it says during the third second the
third second where is the third second
yeah very good so this is the first
second this is the second one so that
makes this the third one I mean because
of the values on the table that's all I
can do now right so this is the third
second the language is so important
because third second is very easy to
confuse with time equals three right but
times with reason instant time ago
street is the end of the third second
right does that make sense so now when I
say average velocity CalFire do I travel
I finally Co yeah five meters I'm still
going in that positive I can say five
and it takes me one second to do that
ring set all makes it okay
Part C skips in his face and turn around
you can try this you can draw this we we
can do this so easily we will do it all
together
okay t squared minus 4 T squared minus 4
you'll notice by the way I've only drawn
the positive side of my time axis why
that because time has been defined here
as T seconds after time zero right now
if they said T seconds after nine
o'clock forty seconds after the first
team T days after the first of January
or whatever it is
in those cases negative time has a
meaning it's like ah it's not that
o'clock it's 859 yeah or it was December
31st or etc okay but here it's a time
zero that's it that's your beginning yes
that's why I'm only doing this part and
as I mentioned before the vertical axis
is your displacement which is X what's
this thing look like
what's this single clock this is just a
problem and it has a vertical intercept
or would have said y-intercept but it's
not only does it it's a vertical
intercept of negative 4 so in where do I
pass by the origin at time equals two
there I am now this is so important this
is again this is a confusing idea of
just like the fact that this is the x
axis rather than the y axis I would say
the language I used to describe this is
that time comes to I'm at the origin now
that's weird because normally we would
say that's the origin right does that
that's usually what we'd say but here
that's at time 0 displacement 0 I've
never actually there right at time 0 I'm
not at x equals 0 I can't possibly be I
only get to x equals 0 no displacement
at time 2 so I would say at that point
at this time rather I am at the
are you okay in fact anytime like
instead of saying a root or an
x-intercept I'm going to say when I pass
the origin that's anytime I cut through
his T axis that's when X is equal to
zero okay so please don't confuse the x
axis means something different in this
same and the origin means something
quite different in this game
all right now I'm on pause there I'll
write up some questions for 3a in a
second this idea of average speed
average velocity the only difference
between them is when you think about
distance right let's uh let's take this
graph and let's suppose it uh it curved
back down to here let's suppose it was a
symmetrical like that okay and I entered
at negative four again then okay let's
see you guys for a second
suppose let's put a time on this it
looks like the two let's call that for
six seconds okay for example then it
takes me to get back to you okay if that
takes me if it takes you six seconds to
get back right let's think about what we
already know which is displacement
versus time okay what's my displacement
in comparison to wherever again it's
zero I've ended back at negative four so
that's my starting point displacement 0
average velocity over these six seconds
is zero all of these velocities are all
positive okay but if I start looking at
this second half of the journey I'm
going to get negative velocities your
average all that and it all comes out
and watch zero but what about the
distance that I traveled okay well
you've gone away from a side point up to
somewhere let's just call this for the
center of interest let's call that two
and then you've come back right now just
look at this for a second
what lengths have you travel
you've got in the positive direction for
half of your journey that's 6 meters on
this game yes 6 minutes and then at a
certain point you turn around and you go
another 6 meters in the negative
direction but this guy doesn't care
which directly you're going in whether
it's positive or negative
you've gone you've traveled a total an
actual name so therefore you've got six
here and you've got six here so your
total they travel is 12 feet how long
does it take you to do 6 seconds so your
speed would have been 2 meters per
second your average speed as you said
right but your velocity your average
velocity is zero okay